we've given the world a lot and we've
got a lot more still to give if we
hadn't do you think Europe would want us
to join them then as now the nation was
divided when the country joined what
would become the European Union
forty-seven years ago it's been a saw
that has refused to heal one politician
keen to wear Brussels message of unity
on her sleeve Margaret Thatcher but
after Ted Heath signed the UK up the new
prime minister became more combative
with the tabloids cheering from the
sidelines she assured me she was always
up for a battle you'll find many
examples of where we are in the majority
and other people are in the minority
they fight their corner in Europe and
we've been a pretty awful state if I
didn't fight ours take you on both
Europe and elements of her own party
proved one fight too many Thatcher was
forced out by pro Europeans her
successor attempted a softer approach
John Major claimed game set and match at
the Maastricht negotiations opting
Britain out of the single currency and
who do you think will be mugging you
over if mrs. Thatcher or mr. Heath I
think that it's a very satisfactory
outcome for Britain within months that
bullish mood was flawed the pound
crashed on Black Wednesday followed by
another battle with Europe the so-called
beef war British meat banned from the
continent after the outbreak of mad cow
disease and the grinding nature of
Brussels marathon conferences was taking
its toll on British politicians and the
media alike at home EU regulatory
pressures on farmers and fishermen began
to manifest themselves into protests
time for fresh blood are they crowd here
chanting Tony Tony Labor's of our Dilip
ROH EU leader Tony Blair swept to power
in 1997 but held back from joining the
next phase of EU integration the euro
Europe was a problem for Britain right
the way through
it's always been a problem for britain
we should have been there at the
beginning that was the start at the end
under political pressure from a surging
you Kip who he'd once dismissed as
fruitcakes loonies and closeted racists
David Cameron called a referendum if you
are reelected in the next parliament you
will offer the country a referendum in
or out I think a referendum is the
cleanest simplest and neatest way of
doing it Boris Johnson through his
charisma behind Lee
Star News is projecting that the UK has
voted out to resume took over and
struggled for three years to deliver on
the referendum brexit knees brexit means
brexit means brexit lee's brexit
parliament had other ideas the noes have
it
the noes have a noes have it
[Applause]
we can get brexit done now but Boris
Johnson was able to break the deadlock
riding brexit all the way to number 10
he has got brakes had done if not quite
on time now he'll be hoping he can
deliver a happy European ending for
himself and the country
Adam Bolton's Sky News Westminster